[Music]
usually drive down the coast I came here
the long way I've been building software
professionally since 1996
I am the organizer of Santa Barbara
JavaScript up the coast I love jazz
music if I were stranded on a desert
island and could take only one genre of
music with me
it'll be jazz it's America's greatest
gift for the world and I'm a dad of two
school-aged kids step-dad to a 19 year
old college student and husband of my
beautiful wife for five years that's me
on twitter follow me there for all sorts
of non sexy cold textured so I'm a
software architecture and pro core
technologies where cloud-based
constructions offer our company and
we're growing like wildfire
Glassdoor meaning us the number four
place overall to work in the US this
year number two in tech ahead of
heavyweights like Facebook Google
Microsoft Amazon etc and we're actively
hiring we got a large react codebase
you're interested in that see me after
the talker in the hallways I'll be happy
to put you in touch with the right
people and I do have some pro core
keychain bottle openers so hit me up
afterwards if you want to try when I'm
not geeking out over tech I'm an avid
scuba diver it's a bad habit don't get
into it it's a major waste of money but
it's a lot of fun all right so why
test-driven development well let's take
a step back for a moment for those who
aren't familiar and let's ask what is
test-driven development well it's a
software development methodology
agnostic and language technology
platform etc and it consists of
repeating a really short development
cycle
red green refactor read is writing a
failing test and watching it fail
knowing it's going to fail
Green is writing just enough code to
make that test pass and committing all
manner of sins to get there and refactor
is changing the internals or optimizing
the internals without breaking the
interface under tests so there's all
sorts of benefits to this methodology
some are technical some are process
based but in my mind the most important
outcome of test-driven development is
that a well-written suite becomes a
shared self documenting understanding of
the problem to me
so it's true that you can actually write
decent tests after the fact and you
could definitely get equivalent coverage
code coverage after the fact the problem
is you may be just asserting the
correctness of bad code or code that
solves the wrong problem in fact you're
kind of just verifying that the monster
lives okay wake up everybody I realized
that this sounds really dry and boring
but the truth is TDD can and should be
fun we first off we get to hook into the
brains own reward system we get to kick
that little dopamine rush off for each
passing test and then when we get a
whole suite of them it makes our
developer brains happy so we all agree
that test-driven development is awesome
right so why would you not want to do
this it turns out a few decades later
this practice is still controversial out
in the wild and there's various
different push backs most of which can
be pretty pretty easily countered it
does definitely feel wrong when you're
first doing it the rest of these can
easily be countered by the benefits that
are given in fact the the last couple
change happens to quickly solution isn't
clear TDD strength as it lets you
systematically close the knowledge gap
between where you are and where you want
to get to so I think you could pretty
easily throw these all in episode of
mythbusters' and maybe firmly busted so
we agree TDD is awesome
why test react components well to start
with there web technologies that we all
know and love are hard and at the end of
the day we're building user interfaces
right we're building something visual
and everybody and their mother has an
opinion on things that are visual and
then in react land we also have this
beast called JSX JSX looks an awful lot
like their web technologies
we're already familiar with it but in
fact it's not these things JSX is just
XML like extensions to the JavaScript
language it's syntactic sugar for the
create element method which just
produces react elements it's not HTML
it's not CSS I think it is JavaScript
got it awesome alright so we agree TDD
is awesome we think we should test our
react components how do we do that when
we think about testing react components
it helps to take a moment think about
the abstractions the react provides and
the primary abstraction that react
provides for us is to model a user
interface as a tree of components and
the docs actually give us some really
helpful little tidbits as we read
through them they tell us that
components are like functions they take
inputs and they return outputs that are
react elements and they go on to say
that they those react elements aren't
dominant they're plain objects and it's
not our responsibility to update the
don't react Dom will do that for us so
there's some really good little nuggets
in there that help us frame this
discussion around how to test react
components the first is components are
like functions they take inputs in
return outputs and there's a little
easier to test than a peer function the
outputs are react elements not Dom
elements those react elements are plain
objects and the Dom is none of your
business
I want to dig into that last point a
little bit more because it's important
it's reflected in the design of react we
actually get one package called react
and that is the core component hash
function and we get a completely
separate package called react Dom that's
responsible for the details of rendering
to the Dom because the Dom is an
implementation detail okay so we saw
from the docs that it's like react
components like a function take inputs
and returns outputs so if we take a
component in its simplest form this is a
basic function component from the docs
and if we just invoke that and pass it
an object with props what we get back is
a react element it's a plane object that
describes what might happen later if we
hand that off to react on this is not
super useful on its own from a testing
point of view there's no API here we
might be able to make some useful
assertions but we're
limited in what we can do so react ships
a package called react test renderer we
speak to it in JSX and we get back an
object with some methods on it like this
- tree method and we get back again a
plane object with a little bit more
detail and it also gives us an API by
which we can query the returned element
and make assertions about it so the docs
don't stop there they go further and
they tell us that if you're writing unit
tests shallow rendering can be helpful
because it frees us from worrying about
child components now this assumes that
unit testing is valuable to you and this
is another thing that's controversial
still out in the wild I believe that
years of testing experience have taught
us that based on cost and speed you
should spend most of your time at the
bottom of the test pyramid on unit tests
UI tests are important and then tests
service and integration tests are
important but they're more expensive
they're slower tend to be more brittle
and from a TDD perspective you're
starting at nothing so you're going to
be building unit tests first so with
that in mind the react test renderer
packages it ships a shallow render very
similar you talk to it in JSX and you
get back a plain object that you can
query it just doesn't render or
instantiate child objects the API is
fairly limited and the docs tell us that
if you want a more robust experience
with shallow rendering to use the
shallow render from enzyme this is a
package from Airbnb this library is also
not without its own controversy and
there are shinier new toys making their
way around the JavaScript ecosystem
there's definitely some legitimate
criticisms of enzyme but on the whole
especially for shallow rendering I think
the pros far outweigh the cons I
wholeheartedly recommend it and it's
what I'm gonna use for the rest of this
talk so all that said we now know the
TDD is awesome we all agree we should be
testing our react components we have
some idea how to do it
what do I mean then by testers and
component development what I'm really
getting at is this tendency to conflate
behavioral and presentational concerns
it's really easy especially in this
world of JSX
to go down the rabbit hole when you
should be testing the behavior or
verifying the behavior of the component
nobody's ever done that right they've
been in the middle of trying to make
something work and then they set it up
on the brows
and that should have a drop shadow that
should be three pictures to the left it
should be red etc
nobody's ever guilty of that so this is
basically applying the methodology of
TDD to focus entirely on the behavior of
a component first without worrying at
all about what it looks like we'll do
that later
we know that TDD forces us to compose or
output small modular single
responsibility units in this case react
components we can then compose those
together and write tests further up the
tree to verify the composition of those
and then we can focus on how they look
we already know that HTML and CSS are
hard so let's put our brains on the back
burner with a bunch of tests running on
the behavioral side of things and then
we can focus solely on the appearance so
what do you think should give a shot
cool so we know that the first thing
we're going to do is we're gonna write a
failing test but first let's have a
little context so we have a small bright
hungry development team and we've been
approached by a client with a unique
problem the clients told us they're
super busy they have a really hard time
keeping track of all the things they
have to do and what they want is an
application where they can type in tasks
they can mark them as complete they can
see which ones have done and not and
they could remove old done tasks and
since nobody in the history of software
engineering has ever built anything like
this our team has agreed that we can
step up to the plate and even though we
don't know how to get there we can use
TDD to bridge that knowledge gap so
we're gonna jump in six months into the
development cycle we're gonna see where
our team is so we know that test-driven
development produces as an artifact a
self documenting shared understanding of
the domain so let's run the tests and
what might be wrong here doesn't
recognize that let's run the tests and
let's see what we get and what we should
get is you should get some idea of what
the team has been up to in the past six
months all right so we've got some
output here let's see what they've been
doing so we can see sort of in plain
English that they've written this to do
component given a place to enter a new
task when a user presses enter and the
task is not empty responds with the task
it looks like they've also created a
component to hold a single to do give it
a task when displayed it shows the name
and whether it's complete or not and
they've written a button that bottom
navigation to switch between active and
completed - dues cool so that gives us
some idea of what they've been up to so
what we're gonna do as we're stepping in
here to help the team out glute for
those things and put them together into
a - duze component that has the input
that shows individual - dues and lets us
toggle between the views so the first
thing we know is we're gonna have to
write a failing test so let's do that so
let's say given a list of tasks when
displayed it shows each task in the list
sounds like a reasonable test right
everyone agree excellent ok so that
means that we're gonna need some tasks
to give this guy so let's add some tasks
so let's create some - dues and we'll
call them nonsensical names
okay cool now we can pass these to our
to do component so let's do that alright
so we've set up our test now we need to
make an assertion about it so what's a
reasonable assertion there we've given
it five to Do's why don't we say that
there's five individual to do components
one for each in the list sound
reasonable let's do it so we're going to
use an enzyme method called find and
we're gonna find our previously written
to do component and we're going to
verify that we have the right number of
them typos at all
okay let's run it and we should expect
that test to fail and it does it
definitely fails it fails with a syntax
error let's fix that first don't you
love that where's my syntax error
everyone help me out here this is the
perils of live coding oh I broke I broke
my my render area denied not to sought
hard let's do two do's that should fix
that okay that's better alright so it
still fails and it gives us this really
cryptic error react creat element type
is invalid so for those who have ever
worked in a statically typed languages
this is the equivalent of like a
compiler what it's telling us is that
the file that has our component and it
has nothing in it and our test run our
just is super helpful in that case gives
us a plain object and react has no idea
what to do with that so let's get
ourselves to at least a meaningful test
here I think that's gonna help us along
so let's grab our to Do's component and
let's just give it a basic react
component call to do's let's save that
now we should have a more meaningful air
great so it says give it a list of tasks
when displayed shows each in the list we
expected 5 we got 0 our test fails
alright and so armed with our failing
test we begin to cry we feel like
perhaps impostor syndrome is real maybe
we can't not cut out for this programmer
thing after all and we should maybe find
a new job
don't despair it's ok this is actually
progress a concrete failure is way
better than some sense that things are
failing and not knowing what's going on
and also and I can't under underscore
this enough if you've never seen a test
fail it's really hard to have confidence
that it's a valid test if you have a
whole suite of tests running in CI and
they always pass and you've never seen
one failed
chances are you have at least some false
positives and one of the things that TDD
gives us is the ability to verify up
front that a test can fail it's a super
important all right so the next step in
our short development cycle is the green
step and that's writing just enough code
to make this test to pass
and that's what we're gonna do and we're
gonna commit all manner of sins and
atrocities to get there so we have this
test it's failing um
I think probably the simplest thing that
we can do to make this test pass is just
a spit out five to do component do we
agree cool let's do it
so let's grab our to do component and
let's just spit out five of them
look bear with me there we go
let's run it and voila it passes
outstanding we got some console errors
there from prop type-checking
fix those later the point is our test
passes you would be cool so what do we
do there we did what's called a
shameless green or sinful green right
and even though the test passes the
implementation is not very useful
because it's very tightly coupled to
that test case if we wrote another test
case and threw it 6 - duze the test
would fail right there tightly coupled
so obviously this is not going to help
us much but what we did was we described
this perfect interface that we want for
our component and we achieved it with a
passing test more importantly we got
that little dopamine rush from our
passing tests our developer brain is
happy we no longer feel like failures
maybe this imposter syndrome thing is
not real maybe we don't have to quit our
jobs we can proceed cool so now the next
step is we're gonna optimize the code
under tests without breaking the test
this is the refactor step so let's go
ahead and do that so I think what we
know what we need to do here right we
can't hard code these to do is we
probably just need to map over that to
dues that were given to us and output
those so let's do that so we have this
to do prop it's a map so we'll get its
entries array and then it will pluck
apart the values in there we've got a
key we'll call it task and we're gonna
have a boolean whether it's complete or
not okay so since we're mapping over
something here we're gonna need a key
and we have a map that has unique keys
so we can use that as our key so we use
the task as the key and then each one
needs it to do which is going to be the
same task and then each one has it is
complete okay and see what we got the
excellent we got a passing test Col
let's just while we're at it let's get
rid of those console warnings and we
know from reading the docs and the tests
that we have an unchanged event we don't
need to implement it right now we just
want to verify that the council warnings
are gone and we also have an on remove
cool
we have passing tests outstanding with
no council warnings so what did we do
there we committed this sinful green the
shameless green that got us to a passing
test and then we went back and fixed it
but chances are if you've been writing
react components for a while you know
what to do right the obvious the clean
implementation is obvious you should
just do it
so I'm not recommending that you
necessarily do these silly little in
between steps unless you don't know how
to reach the optimal solution sometimes
it won't be clear how to get from your
perfect interface to the right clean
solution so you get to refactor in small
steps until you get there and the
gentleman that coined the term
test-driven development guy named by the
neighbor Kent back in his book TDD by
example says that and he says this over
and over and over again throughout the
book TDD is not about taking teeny tiny
steps it's about being able to take
teeny tiny steps and he goes on to say
that if you all you ever do is take
large steps how would you know that a
smaller step might actually solve the
problem better so that's it in a
nutshell that's TDD
it's just that cycle and then you just
repeat it over and over and over again
till your application is done so in the
spirit of that let's go ahead and do so
let's repeat it and we have one test
right now this component is not super
useful for us we can display some to
do's but right now the user can't
interact with it so let's write another
test probably the first thing a user is
going to want to do is to add a new task
so let's go ahead and do that let's
write a test for that let's say when a
user chooses to add a new task
it shows the new task in the list so
good cool so we're gonna need to render
out the component again and we'll
bootstrap it with that same set of -
duze okay there's our arrangement by the
way a test a good test usually is in
three phases arranged
acta sir
so here's our arrangement now we're
gonna need to act so we already have
some components pre-built by our team we
have that individual to do component
we've also got this to do input
component and it's been tested we know
that it works and has a public contract
and in that public contract is a prop
called unchanged so here we're unit
testing this component in isolation we
don't need to worry about how that
internals with that other component
behave we're verifying that a callback
this component provides - it works
correctly and results in the right
output so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna find that to do input and we're
just going to directly call its on
change problem the unchanged prop is
provided by this component so we are
going to find that to do input component
and then we're going to get its props
collection and then we're just going to
call the unchanged method now but we're
gonna need to call it with something now
we're gonna need a new to do let's say
we're just gonna call it to do and let's
create that above so let's create a new
to do and we're gonna do something and
we're gonna fix that little typo there
okay cool so we're gonna cast it back
into the fiery chasm from whence it came
all right so at this point we've acted
now now we're gonna rush search
something about our action so there's
probably two assertions we could make
here that would be equally valid we
bootstrap this thing with five - duze we
can assert that now there's six and
that's a perfectly valid assertion but I
always prefer specificity and I think
there's a more specific assertion we
could make here and that's that we can
find it to do whose to do prop matches
that exactly so we're gonna do that so
let's make an assertion let's expect
that this is a really odd angle to type
AB
pardon my typos so we're gonna do first
is we're going to find all the to Do's
and then we're gonna call a more
granular version of find called find
where
and find where lets you run a predicate
over all the nodes all the children in
the tree and then it'll return those
that match the predicate so our
predicate is going to be that there's a
prop called or a azaab we're gonna find
a prop called to do
oops pardon me we're going to find a
prop called to do and that we're gonna
expect that it matches exactly but to do
that we just defined and then we're
gonna check that it exists and this is
going to tell us that at least one of
them exists or we'll expect that to be
true cool and let's run the test and we
should expect the test to fail and we
have an unexpected token so it's
definitely going to fail where did we
break it helped me out folks first one
to spot it gets a prize it looks like
it's here right there's the problem all
right
good okay cool so we got a failure as
expected and the failure tells us that
method props is meant to be run on one
node zero found instead and then it
shows us the line where that occurs
basically it's telling us it can't find
to do input right because we haven't
implemented it yet so let's go ahead and
implement it let's go back to our unit
under test so we're gonna need to import
that and then we're gonna need to render
one out right okay and then we also know
because we're invoking it that we're
gonna have to cut we're gonna have to
give it a non change and for the sake of
simplicity let's just call it on change
and then our job is going to be to
implement that so we know what's going
to take it to do now what are we gonna
do here
well we have some idea because we've
described the behavior that we want in
our test we basically have said that
when the user triggers this change event
that our new to do just magically
appears right
which probably implies some state we
can't mutate the props that are passed
in so it probably implies that we're
gonna have state means we're gonna need
a stateful component now in the old days
say in our last October that would have
meant that we would need a class
component that extends react component
but the folks at Facebook that work on
react
came up with an alternative API that
lets you hook into things like state
management from function components it's
called the hooks API this is good
because the overhead of classes is often
not needed and more importantly
javascript doesn't have classes
javascript just has syntax sugar on top
of constructors and prototype chains so
we're gonna use the use state hook so
we're gonna need to import it first and
it looks something like this
you give it the name of the state
container there's a setter provided for
you and then we'll initialize it with
the two dews that are passed in or we
don't get one we'll just initialize it
with a new map and then what that means
is that we should just be able to call
the setter or the mutated collection so
we should just be able to do set to dues
and just add our new one initialize to
false okay and we're almost done there's
just one more thing here that we're
gonna need to do to make this work first
one the spot it gets extra credit it's
alright I'll give it away right now
we're still reading off off the props
the read-only props that are passed in
so we actually need to read from our new
State container okay now we have syntax
errors all over the place what do we do
we broke something oh I know what it is
all right we're still broken would it be
break now we broke something
we broke one of our previous tests right
yeah no that's it help me out folks what
did we break hmm
we're in the source of the test right
here right here ah yeah thank you that
is outstanding thanks for the help
thanks for the assist
all right cool all right
so we have now what we're gonna do is
we're gonna fast forward another six
months you can tell like these things
take a long time for anyone that
actually works in the real world knows
that simple things take a long time in
the real world um we're gonna fast
forward six months and we're gonna let
our team continue along this journey of
test-driven development before they've
even looked at it in a browser and then
what's going to happen is they're gonna
have a fully functional application and
they haven't yet looked at it in the
browser it's probably going to look like
crap this is amazon.com when it launched
in 1999 by today's standards this looks
like absolute rubbish but it was a very
successful e-commerce site that allowed
Amazon to become the juggernaut that
they are today and this leads us then to
the really neat thing about test-driven
component development and that is that
we can treat the visual look and feel
portion of it as refactoring with
passing tests so we've already proven
that it works right now we can actually
set aside the behavioural part which was
hard right and we can let our tests run
and now we can focus on something else
that's hard which is CSS and HTML making
things look great so let's catch up with
the team and
see how they've done so the first thing
we're gonna do of course is to run our
tests and see how far they've come on
that component that we started helping
them with and what we can see is that
they were able to select only the active
tasks complete one and verify that it is
removed from the active tasks if you do
the opposite with completed tasks they
can delete one and they can remove one
so we're gonna do here is I'm going to
shrink these tests down not important
that you guys can read the individual
tests out there we just want to verify
that they're not breaking and then we
are going to stand up a browser over
here and we are going to let's go ahead
and get this guy here and I've got the
dev server running in the background and
the first thing we're gonna do is verify
that it in fact it actually does work
we've made this bold claim that we could
build an application without looking at
it so let's just see
can we add a new task it looks like we
can this is good this is progress
can't wait let's see all the active one
to see if we can complete one it looks
like we can looks good and let's see if
we can remove that it looks like it's
gone and then let's see if we can remove
them all okay cool so it worked it looks
like crap it's all just basic HTML
components there's no real pizzazz here
no style if we put different links
strings they're all off they're not
lined up it looks kind of like rubbish
so with that in mind let's do a little
bit of visual refactoring I'm gonna
cheat here and I'm gonna use component
library for some prettiness I'm gonna
use material your eye not because I
recommend it over other libraries the
real reason is a lot more practical and
that is that it's the one that's easiest
to drop into a project with no config
and no style sheets and it just looks
good so I'm gonna use that and I think
what we can do here let's go ahead swap
that out for a card all right let's make
it a flexbox
and let's make it not fill the whole
width let's say 90% let's line it laughs
this is a really odd angle to type from
all right that should be good enough
cool and then I think if we just wrap
these guys in their own container and
give it a flex of one
unless see what that looks like
good said here we go okay alright we're
getting somewhere
cool all right so we can also if we want
so we've just changed the mark up we
could also or like wrap this in a span
and everything should still work let's
just make sure that it works first and
then we'll prove it by looking at the
tests and the tests are all still
passing so if you've written good tests
if you've written tests that are
agnostic of implementation details you
can you should be able to move your
markup around style it add additional
wrapper components and everything should
still just work cool so let's jump ahead
just one more time here let's see what
the team has been up to for the next six
months just doing visual refactoring
working with the client and let's see
what we get let's run the tests just
make sure everything is still running
and you can see now our UI looks a
little bit glossy err we've got these
great little animated radio buttons
everything looks pretty cool so let's
just add one more task whoops well Jess
Kong is close enough let's mark that
sucker off the list
alright cool the perils of live coding
and so what did we do here we learned
that test-driven development is a thing
that it's good that testing react
components is worthwhile and important
we learned that using this technique we
could free ourselves from completing
behavior own presentational concerns
even though they're co-located in one
file we could focus on making components
work and then we could free ourselves to
focus on how they look we're happy our
customers happy and now we can get paid
and that's all I got
thanks a lot there's the repo that's me
on Twitter
[Applause]
[Music]